>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good afternoon.
I'm Ron Charles, Editor of the
Washington Post Book Section and I'm
so delighted that you're here today.
First, a word of thanks for our
co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubinstein, and many
other sponsors who've made this
event possible.
And if you'd like to make a
financial donation to this festival,
there's information in your
program to make that happen.
We will have some time for
questions when I'm done.
There's a microphone
there and there.
If you come to the microphone to
ask a question, you will be recorded
and become part of the
Library's permanent collection.
So if that's not something you
want to do, stay in your seat.
Okay. My guest this afternoon is
Lauren Groff, the author of two
of my favorite novels,
"Arcadia" and "Fates and Furies."
[ Applause ]
But she has much bigger
fans than me.
Her first book, "Monsters of
Templeton," got a rave review
from Stephen King, who
was just here a few hours.
>> I know, yeah.
>> Probably looking
for your autograph.
>> No.
>> And her most recent, listen
to this, her most recent novel,
"Fates and Furies," was
President Obama's favorite book.
Thank you so much for
being here today.
>> Thank you for doing this with me.
Thank you for being here.
This is really lovely.
>> It is. Now let's start.
Since we're in Washington, what
is it like to have the leader
of the free world recommend
your book?
>> So I passed out.
I really did.
I was like, what just happened?
Came to, called my husband and
was like, get home, right now.
And he came home, and I said
you don't have champagne, go.
And he went out and got
champagne, and came back.
So the thing is, I
was really astonished
that he has time for fiction.
>> Yes.
>> But not surprised, because
he's a good human being, right?
Yes.
>> How did you hear, though?
What was the actual moment
when you heard the news?
>> Okay, believe it or not, Twitter.
I was on Twitter, and
someone tweeted it at me.
And I said, that's not true.
And I went and then I saw it
in People Magazine, which,
again, it was very surreal.
And I'm just astonished.
But you know what?
He's such a kind and
gracious human being
that he actually sent
a note to my house.
>> Wow.
>> Which I framed, and it's the
thing after the kids and the dog
that I will save if it ever comes
to that, because I love the man.
>> The dogs and the kids,
they will leave you.
>> They will run away, but I will go
and get the framed note
from Barack Obama, yeah.
>> That's great.
I should also note that "Fates
and Furies" was shortlisted
for the National Book Award,
the National Book Critics
Circle Award, the Kirkus Award.
It was on dozens of best-seller
lists, including ours.
>> Thank you.
>> And recommended lists,
end-of-the-year lists.
It was just a tremendous,
tremendous novel.
People who don't know, "Fates
and Furies" is about a long
and passionate marriage between
a very successful playwright
and his wife.
The first half of the novel
focuses on the husband,
and the second half
focuses on the wife.
And they turn out to have very
different lives, and very,
very different perspectives,
both of them fascinating.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Now, Lotto is brilliant and
vain and self-aggrandizing,
but he's really sort of
charming, too, and wonderful.
And Mathilde is quiet
and supportive and meek,
but also kind of sneaky and furious.
Yes. Now, you haven't really written
enough novels to have a type,
but I was completely
surprised by this novel.
>> Okay.
>> If it's not a departure, it seems
like a really daring novel to write
in so many ways, and did
you start thinking about it
as a novel in two distinct halves?
How did that whole structure evolve?
>> Believe it or not, I actually
thought four or five years,
I was writing two separate novels,
because I wanted to do Mr. Bridge
and Mrs. Bridge, but like redux.
And it didn't work out at
all, at all, in any way.
And, so I gave it to my agent,
who's a great, great mega agent,
and we were sitting at
this sort of dive vegan,
I don't even know what it was, café
in New York City, and I was picking
up this piece of [inaudible] cake.
And he goes, "Lauren," and he sits
forward, and he pushes the two parts
of the book, which I thought were
two books, together, and he goes,
"You have made a marriage, two
autonomous parts within a whole."
And I was like, "Oh,
you're a genius!
Thank you!"
So, yeah, it is.
Then I had to do a lot of work
after that, but he helped a lot.
>> You weren't resistant.
You realized instantly that's --
>> No, no, no, I cried.
I always cry whenever he talks
to me, but after a good --
after about two hours, I
ended up being okay with it,
and realizing he's right.
I mean it's a marriage
in a lot of ways.
He's always right,
and I'm always wrong.
>> It's tempting to think that
Lotto is the wholly deluded one,
and then we find out the
truth in the second half,
but it's really not so
simple at all, is it?
>> No. No, I tried hard not to do
that, but of course, if you believe
that this book is actually Mathilde,
that's kind of okay with me,
because one of my inspirations
was Vera Nabokov,
and she was this mega
genius herself,
but she completely effaced herself.
And Stacy Schiff is here.
She wrote this beautiful,
beautiful book about Vera.
And that was actually the
inspiration behind a part
of -- that part of the book.
And if, so if you do believe that
the book is actually Mathilde's,
it's almost revenge for all
of the wives who've had
to hide in the corner.
But in truth, I actually
really wanted it to be a story
that could be truthful in
multiple different ways, right.
I wanted to have it sort of resound,
depending on where you, the reader,
are in your life, in any particular
way that you respond to it.
There's no single truth.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> It is very unstable.
>> In a fascinating way.
It seems very traditional
in some sense.
You've got this outgoing,
successful man,
and then the power
behind the throne,
this woman who's pulling
all the strings.
But in the second half, we find out
that's so much more complex, that --
I'm sorry, I'm mispronouncing
her name.
Mathilde?
>> That's how I say it, but you
can say it however you like.
You're [inaudible].
It's good.
>> No. So I'm thinking Lady Macbeth.
>> Yeah.
>> Livia.
>> The Emperor's wife.
As you thought about
her personality,
did she take on that sort of
maniacal character for you?
Or did she remain a
really human person?
>> For me, she was
always very, very human,
which means that like every other
human in my life, I may love her,
but I don't necessarily
like her, right?
I say this -- I'm the mother of two
small children, and you love them
so desperately, but they're hard to
like sometimes, and it's very true.
So throughout, I saw her as
this person that, in many ways,
I would actually like to be
like Mathilde in certain ways.
She is so clear-sighted.
>> Yeah.
>> She's so able to sort of know how
a small change right now will affect
everybody else in the future.
So she's almost like a mathematical
genius in a certain way,
but she's so reserved, right?
>> Yes.
>> And she's self-effacing,
but in a self-willed way
that makes her somewhat
difficult to cling to.
And she's really, really angry.
She's furious.
And that part of her I
really liked, actually.
I love her rage.
I think it's the animating
feature of her.
>> I want to talk about
rage for a minute.
>> Okay.
>> Because it's such a --
we use that as such a way to
denigrate women, don't we?
They cannot ever be bitter or angry.
Strong, yes, maybe, but
not angry or bitter.
And I think the way you bring
that out is so powerful.
There's a lot of mythology
in your earlier works.
It's, I think, very evident.
But there's mythology in
this book, too, isn't there?
Isn't there?
>> Yes, I thought at
first you said --
I thought at first you said
pathology, and I thought --
>> I lost my voice --
>> Probably.
>> At the party last night.
I talked way too long.
>> All right.
>> Mythology.
>> There is, there's
a lot of mythology.
Yeah, there's mythology everywhere,
because I can't get away from it,
but I love it so much, right?
Yeah.
>> Yeah, let's talk
about the mythology.
>> Okay.
>> In your first book, for instance.
>> What -- did you
study those myths?
Did you love those myths
when you were a child?
What is it about mythology
that you like?
>> Well, in the first book, the
myths were mostly about Cooperstown,
New York, where I'm from.
>> That's a classic America place.
>> It's very Americana, yeah.
>> Yes.
>> And James Fenimore Cooper is from
there, his father started the town,
but also baseball is, itself,
very much a myth, right?
>> It is mythological, yes.
>> Mythological.
Like the foundation of it.
It actually didn't
start in Cooperstown.
Everybody knows this, and yet they
all go there to the Hall of Fame.
My house, when I was growing up, was
a block and half away from the Hall
of Fame, and so when
Phillies, in particular,
came to celebrate the induction
of Phillies, they would,
like camp out on my yard.
But -- so I'm deeply in love
with this idea that we all live
within this net of stories, right?
>> Yes.
>> We were caught in
this net of stories.
And the stories we can
use to tell the story
of ourselves, in a certain way.
And I think that we can't get away
from the narrative that we spin
for ourselves, and for our
towns, and for our places.
So in that book, in particular,
is a very local set of myths.
In this book, it's a much
different set of myths.
I think it's much more dependent
on Greek mythology, but also --
>> Yes.
>> The myths of narrative.
A lot of different prototypes
of narrative are happening.
>> You're thinking of Medea?
>> Oh, yeah, I am.
Antigone, right?
Because I actually wrote
an opera about Antigone.
>> You wrote an opera?
>> Well, in the book
there's an opera.
>> Oh, yes, I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I have read the book.
>> But I tried to write
it as an actual opera,
and no musician wanted
to do it with me.
I was really depressed.
I think it would be amazing, right?
>> Yeah, it would.
>> Maybe there'd be a
puppet in the middle of it?
Dancers? I can see razzmatazz.
But I think in this particular
case, what I was so fascinated
by is the idea that Greek mythology
exists within a separate kind
of plane of storytelling.
I mean, the stories that we tell
now feel very terrestrial, right?
You're walking on the earth,
you're going from one place
to another in a lot of them.
But Greek mythology exists within
sometimes even competing stories
of the same characters, right?
>> Yes.
>> And the gods are these large
overweening characters that sort
of exist up here, and they're so --
they're involved in
everything, right?
They're responsible
for everything, but --
and the mortals are these
little, like, people down here
that are easily crushed, and -- so
what I like is that there are --
there's a multiplicity of time
happening with the Greek myths.
>> Yes.
>> Because there's this larger
elemental time happening up here,
and this small mortal almost
granular time happening down here.
And then you, the consumer
of the myth,
are somewhere in here,
in the middle.
>> Yes.
>> And it's almost like
you're in an aquarium, right?
And these are the sharks and
those are the hermit crabs,
and you can see them
coming in and out.
>> Yes.
>> So what I love so much about
it is this idea of flexibility
and layers in terms of storytelling.
I find it so fascinating
and wonderful.
>> It is.
>> And that's what I
wanted for this book.
That's why I structured
it the way that I did.
>> Aren't you surprised when
you read the myths, like Medea
and Antigone, how contemporary
and powerful they are?
>> Oh, God, yes.
>> Even though they're --
I mean, you read some stories
that are 300 years old,
and they're already so dated
you can barely understand them,
they don't speak to you at all.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Then you read these plays,
and they seem so immediate.
>> I think part of it is that
they're boiled down to the bones,
in a way that almost the
fairytales are sort of --
>> Yes.
>> They're just the story.
>> Right.
>> And we put onto the characters
all the flesh as readers.
And the same thing with
the Greek mythology.
But all of the -- what
the Greeks are talking
about are these elemental emotions.
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> And I don't think, I mean,
human technology has changed,
but humanity has not
changed all that much
in the past few thousand years.
>> Right.
>> Deeply, I mean, in
terms of emotional.
>> Right.
>> Things.
>> Right. And in "Arcadia,"
it is about mythology
or the mythologies we create
about our past and our childhood.
Long after Bit realizes what
that commune's really like,
he still is haunted by what
he imagines it was like.
And those two things compete
for the rest of his life.
>> And what he imagines
it could've been, too.
>> Right.
>> I mean, he's actually --
that's the thing that haunts
him the most, I think.
>> And it, of course, it can't be.
>> It could never be, right?
Because we humans are flawed.
>> Right.
>> Firmly.
>> All those utopian communities
end in essentially the same --
>> Yeah.
>> Way.
>> Except for, I think,
religious communities, which are,
in a way, utopian, right?
>> Right.
>> I mean, they could
be seen as utopian.
>> Right.
>> People are devoted to a more
perfect union, so -- and the Amish.
>> Right.
>> Very successful.
>> That's true.
That's still going on, you're right.
>> Yes.
>> And "Fates and Furies" is about
the mythology of marriage in a way.
The stories we tell, the
stories we want to be true,
the stories we cling to even
after we realize it's not true.
>> Right.
>> You're married.
>> I'm very married, yes.
>> I imagine.
>> Where are we going?
Yes?
>> I imagine a story about two
beautiful people who are married,
and then you write a
novel about [inaudible].
I imagine people are
always pestering you
about the autobiographical roots
of this novel, aren't they?
>> Right, yes.
>> And it must drive you crazy.
>> No, because I played
with it intentionally.
>> Really.
>> Yeah. Because I knew as a
female writer, I'm always going
to be asked these questions.
Men are almost never
asked these questions.
Women are almost always
>> You sniveling women.
>> We scribbling lady
novelists, that's right.
>> That's it.
>> And, you know, I've been
annoyed by this question
since I've been writing books,
but in the last few books,
in fact the books that have been
published, I have been playing
with this question a lot.
>> Yes.
>> And I've been playing
intentionally
with the readers' response to it,
because if you can't combat it,
why not play with it, right?
>> Yes.
>> So I put certain elements
of me into the story,
and if you know me really well,
you'll see my husband, particularly,
in Lotto, in a way that
it's a joke, right?
I mean, he's not Lotto
at all in any way.
>> Yeah.
>> But I put, I mean, my husband
is 6' 6" and so is Lotto, right?
>> Yes.
>> We met rowing, right?
>> So a lot of things
are in the book,
seated in the book
intentionally to play
with this idea of autobiography.
>> And how can the reader
participate in that play?
>> Oh, because they're
always asking the question
when they're reading, right?
>> And what do you tell them?
>> I tell them everything is
autobiographical, but not.
>> So they think, oh, it's really
about her and her husband, yes.
>> Yeah. It's okay.
You can think whatever you want.
>> Does it kind of
freak your husband
out to read the book
and see these elements?
These echoes?
>> He's the phlegmatic,
so the answer is no.
He's totally fine with
what I write, and it's --
so, okay, he hasn't always
been fine with what I write.
>> Yes?
>> The very first short story
I ever showed him, and this is,
you know, years into my writing.
We were just dating, and I gave
it to him, and he saw himself
in the character, and
he wrote "bleh"
on the paper, and then
threw it at me.
So he's gotten much better.
>> Wow, yeah.
>> And now he's really
great about it.
Now he writes me these
single-spaced,
you know, 12-page letters.
>> Come on.
He writes you letters?
>> No, I can't take it verbally.
>> So you're sitting
there in the same room,
and he's writing you a letter?
>> Yes.
>> And then you read it while
he's sitting next to you?
>> No. I go into another room.
But I know that if he responds to
the text at hand through text --
>> Yes?
>> He's able to see it almost
intellectually as a different thing,
as not reflective of
our lives together.
>> That's got to be hard.
>> To live with me, absolutely.
It is not easy.
He is not a saint,
but he's pretty close.
>> Is his criticism helpful?
>> Every time.
>> Really?
>> Yes, because he's a really
smart general reader, right?
>> Nice.
>> And I think a lot of times
we rely on other writers
who know the same tricks that we do.
>> Right.
>> And so there's almost a shorthand
that I think we take for granted.
But the really smart general
reader will ask questions
that a writer won't.
>> Right.
>> So, yeah.
>> Now, Lotto is married longer
than you've been married.
>> Oh, yes.
>> How did you project yourself
into that undiscovered
country of a long marriage?
>> Well, they're only married
for 26 years, which is, I mean,
I've been with my husband for 19,
so it's only seven more years.
>> Okay, so you're getting close.
>> We're getting close, yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> But how did you think how
a long marriage would evolve?
They're also older than you.
>> They're, yes, they're
older than, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, you know, I have
eyes and friends, so.
>> You mean you used
your imagination?
>> I did, also.
But, you know, you sort of watch
the way that your parents --
my parents are still together
very happily, and I watch the way
that their relationship
has unrolled.
And my friends, I've got friends
who've been together for, you know,
30 years, and so you just ask
a lot of questions a little bit
on the side so they don't quite
know what you're getting at.
>> Until they read your book.
>> Until they read your book
and see themselves in it, yeah.
Yeah.
>> In almost every
interview I've read with you
at some point you say I'm a
private person, a shy person.
>> Yes.
>> Here we are.
Is there something about the
way we've constructed the modern
publishing world that we make
people like you leave your rooms,
and your offices, and your
homes, and go out on tour
and talk and meet with readers.
Are we making it hard for a certain
kind of author, do you think,
to read and publish nowadays
that we didn't in the past?
>> I do think so.
Yeah, but then again,
there's Elena Ferrante,
who does the exact opposite.
>> That's true.
>> Which is she became a cipher.
>> Yes.
>> I mean, she's just
words on the page.
And, actually, she's
playing with that, too.
>> Definitely.
>> I really think that her game
is one of tempting the reader
to see the autobiography in the
text in every one of her books.
I think she's really playing a game.
But I do think in our publishing
community, it's really, really,
really hard to be a
hermit and a writer.
>> It is.
>> So, what you do is you
develop a personae, right?
>> Yes.
>> It's like a Scooby suit that
you unzip at the end of the night,
and it falls to the floor,
and the tender little writer
gets out and like cringes.
>> Was it hard for you
to do this kind of stuff?
>> Well, at first it was.
I really, really hated it
for the first two books.
But now I love it.
>> That's good.
That's good.
Well, we're glad you're here.
This will sound weird, but
you already know what I think
of your book, but I didn't realize
how good it was until I started
to talk to people who hate it.
>> Oh, good.
>> Yes. Because what -- hang on.
No, because the really great
books generate strong opinions
on all sides.
>> Okay.
>> No? No.
And it led to great discussions.
It means it's a great
book for a book club.
It means it's something to say.
It means the book is
really touching people.
That's what really
impressed me about it.
Have you talked to people who
have wildly different views?
Or are people too shy
around you to tell you?
>> No, people definitely
tell me, yeah.
I get lots of emails.
>> And how do you react to that?
>> Oh, erase.
No, I mean -- you know,
I'm actually pretty tough.
I can take a lot of
critique, but not at the time
that a book is published.
>> Of course.
>> I am really, really,
really, really tender.
I can't actually read my reviews.
I can't exist in the
world in which I feel
like people are judging
me, which is really hard.
>> Yes.
>> So I take a step back, and
I let my husband do all that,
and he really does.
He collects all the critiques.
>> The useful critiques.
He puts them on a Word document,
and then two or three years
down the line, I say, all right,
give it to me, and I take it.
But, you know, I care.
I really, really care.
I really want to be a much better
writer than I am now, so I really,
I need to take this, the
things that people are saying.
>> Right.
>> But I need to choose who
I'm hearing from, right?
>> Yes, definitely, yes.
>> And you can't take just
anybody's point of view.
>> No. Of course not.
>> Yeah.
>> I agree with that.
>> Right. I heard you wanted
to be a poet for a while?
>> Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Which makes sense.
Your writing is gorgeous.
>> Thank you.
Yeah.
>> So no collections of
poetry published by you?
>> Oh, God, no.
If I did, it would
be under a pseudonym.
>> So you may have published poetry?
>> Possibly.
[ Laughter ]
The thing is, what I love
about poetry is not what makes
one a good poet, I think.
I really love the form.
I love the formal poetry,
just desperately,
because I love the ideas that
come out of being constrained
to a very small amount of space.
>> The way the discipline
shapes the language?
shapes the language.
I think that's really fun, but I --
and I know there are lots of
really good formal poets out there.
>> Yes.
>> But I am not -- I'm just not
one of them, which is unfortunate.
>> Well, no, I mean, you
bring that poetic [inaudible]
to your writing, I think.
I also heard that you
write in longhand still?
>> I do. Yes.
>> Well, that seems really
surprising, because you're
of a generation, you grew
up, I suppose, on a computer.
>> Yeah.
>> What made you begin to do that?
>> So I -- it's very -- it much more
sensual, actually, in a way, right?
So if you're writing with paper,
the paper has pores in
it, like human skin.
It smells like paper, and the ink
on the paper smells different, too.
And your body is sort of engaged
in a way that if you're writing
on a computer, you're sort of
almost pushing your work away,
in a certain way.
But also at the same
time, I think I'm afraid
of setting things in
stone too early.
>> Yes.
>> And on the computer screen,
it almost looks as though --
the text almost looks as though
it is printed text, right?
>> Yes.
>> So it's actually much,
much harder to change
than when you're just writing
along on a madcap [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> And it's on paper, and you can
go in and you can put in other ink
and you can just throw things away.
I throw tons of things away.
>> Do you really?
>> Yeah, in fact, I write a
really fast first few drafts,
and I throw them out in
between, and then a --
and for this book, it
was about 12 drafts.
So what happens is the first
draft was about a month.
Well, actually the first draft was
these huge pieces of butcher paper
on the walls that I
was writing Mathilde
and Lotto back and forth like chess.
>> What was on those
pieces of paper?
>> Oh, just like little
stories that I would write.
I would write a Mathilde story,
and then turn around and write it
from Lotto's point of view.
>> Oh, so you keep
track of these things?
>> Yeah, well, yeah, well,
and then I threw them out.
And then, yeah, but then I
moved them to actual paper,
and wrote what I thought was
the story in about a month,
and then the stories in a month, and
then threw that out, and kept going,
and kept going, and kept going.
What this does for me,
and I love it so much,
is that it doesn't
set anything in stone.
And because I love the sentence
so much, I can spend all
of my time just fixing one
single sentence, when in reality,
the foundational issues are
what I need to address, right?
The character needs to
become bigger, and stranger,
and all of the peripheral characters
need to have their own back stories.
And so the first few, usually about
five or six drafts of anything
that I write is just junk, and I
let it be junk, because I think
that that's the way, as in
this Leonard Cohen song,
the cracks are the way
the light gets in, right?
And so you intentionally build
into the process a lot of cracks.
That's what I do, at least.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> The style of that
first half of the book
in that lush, romantic tone --
>> Yeah.
>> That you begin to realize is
Lotto's reflection of himself.
>> Right.
>> Or at least that's
what I thought.
>> Right, yes.
>> It's just gorgeous.
>> Oh, thanks.
>> Just so gorgeous.
And the harsh, bitter tone
of that second half is just
as perfect in a different way.
>> Oh, thanks.
>> It is really a triumph.
>> Well, the first half I'm building
out of other narrative
techniques, right?
So like the courtly
romance is in there.
>> Yes.
>> And the opera is in there.
>> You hear Fitzgerald in there.
>> Yeah, the Fitzgeralds,
and the men who are
entranced with themselves --
>> Yeah.
>> Are in there, right?
>> Or just men.
The male creator is
in the first part.
The [inaudible] is in there,
the [inaudible] is in there.
I mean all different kinds
of narrative techniques I
intentionally threw into that.
>> Yes.
>> On purpose in order to have fun.
This book was so much fun to write.
>> Was it?
>> Yes. Oh, my God.
>> That's good to hear.
>> It was great.
It was lovely.
I enjoyed the heck out of it.
But, and the second half, I
was really relying on a lot
of the mid-century French
writers, like [foreign name]
and [foreign name] and a lot of
the writers of the [foreign word],
because I really, I
think that the way
that they write is very
feminine in a lot of ways.
>> Yes.
>> With a lot of leaps and a lot
of fragments, and different ways
of writing than what
we've seen in the past,
with the very romantic sort of
long sentences and lushness.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> That's fascinating.
How do you know when you're done?
[inaudible]
>> Oh, you don't.
Yeah, no, you never
know if you're done.
>> Until the deadline comes?
>> You just get really tired.
Yeah. I got to the point where, you
know, I think it was I had to pay
for health insurance, and I was
like, what am I going to do?
I guess I better give
my agent these books.
[ Laughter ]
So yeah, that's what happens, right?
The pressures of the
capitalism on creativity.
>> But you must have a
sense, this chapter --
I was just talking
to Joyce Carol Oates,
and she does not revise the whole
novel, she revises each chapter
until it's perfect,
and then she moves
to the next chapter,
and the next chapter.
>> Yeah, different people have
different ways of working, right?
And my friend, Kevin Brockmeier
will only fix a sentence for as long
as it takes, and then move
onto the next sentence, right?
>> Very incremental.
>> It's super incremental, and what
that means, though, is at the end,
when he gives it to his editor,
the editor has one or two things
to say, because it's perfect.
Whereas my poor editor, she
wrote me 30 single-spaced pages.
>> Oh, that's a --
>> Yeah, well, she's good.
And it was after I had, I had
probably five or six other readers
in between, too, including my agent,
who is also a very good editor, so,
I mean, I'm not as perfect
as Kevin Brockmeier.
>> And do you accept all
30 single-spaced pages?
>> Oh, God, no.
No, no, no, because a
lot of it is, you know,
tracing what would happen if, right?
So she's like well, in the
first chapter this happens,
what would happen if?
And she would go through the rest
of the book saying then these
things would be changed, too.
>> Right.
>> So I don't always.
I take maybe 50%, yeah.
>> Okay, yeah.
And I thought as I was reading
it, had you written plays before?
>> Well, I tried.
I'm not very good at it.
So, yeah, I really, I love plays.
And I especially love operas.
I just love operas, because they're
so colorful, and it's [inaudible],
you know, it's the
synthesis of many,
many different kinds of artwork.
It's the -- it's music, and
it's singing, and it's acting,
and it's costume, and it's light.
I mean, every kind of art on the
stage happening in the moment
as the audience is reacting
to it, and I love that.
>> Yes.
>> That sort of -- the
feeling of just temporality,
and the idea that the story is
passing by, and all you have
to do is just reach
out and grab it, right?
>> Yes.
>> And I love plays, too,
and particularly my favorite
recently has been Annie Baker,
whom I think is just
a mega, mega genius.
She's so good.
But I've tried to write them, but
my sensibility's really novelistic.
So I end up putting in way too much.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> It's very sad.
>> Well, it's interesting,
because you've read novels
about great poets, but you never
read any poetry in the novel.
The novel always just sort
of points to the poetry
that is somehow, we have to imagine.
>> Well, [inaudible] did.
She did a really good job.
Yeah.
>> It was bold of you to
include actual pages of dialogue
from the plays that we
are told are classics.
>> Bold or stupid.
>> I thought it was bold.
It was a fantastic novel.
I know people want to
ask you questions, too.
So, would you take some
questions from the audience?
>> I will take any questions.
>> Okay.
>> About anything.
>> There's a microphone
here and here.
Come to the mic and ask away.
>> Thank you in advance for
being whoever is the first person
to ask a question.
>> Here comes -- there are
people coming toward the mics.
>> There are.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> Hi.
>> A couple of thoughts
and questions.
Did you set out to write a
book about their marriage?
I think one of things that
resonates, everybody I know
who read it, somewhere
lurking in that story is a bit
about your own marriage, and
we read it for our book club.
And when, you know, word got
out that it was the
President's favorite book,
one of my friends would
say, "Oh, my God.
I cannot believe that that
was his favorite book!
What is it telling us
about their marriage?"
>> We all had that thought.
>> So I was sort of wondering
about that, because, you know,
you never know anyone's marriage,
but I thought it was a wonderful
book and one of the books that,
as soon as I read it, I put it
on my husband's side of the bed
and said, you must read this book.
>> Thank you.
>> And the other thing I thought
that was interesting about it was
that it was a modern, you know,
it was placed in modern times.
It wasn't really set in any
specific time, so in that sense,
it made me -- it felt
like it was evergreen.
>> Okay.
>> In a way that, like, I don't
know if you've read "A Little Life,"
but "A Little Life," I don't know,
was it set in post-9/11 New York,
or was it set in somewhere else?
Because it's just very internal, and
I think that that is also the secret
of its success, because, you
know, you could be in your 70s
and have been married
for ages and read it,
but it's not set in a time outside.
So did you intentionally
want to make it so internal?
>> Well, the first
question about the marriage,
the way that I was envisioning
this book, the books,
when I was writing them, is I
wanted to write a book that was
about marriage the way
that a bomb casing is
about the bomb inside, right?
So it's not about the casing,
it's about the explosion
in a certain way.
And I think the book is set
in a particular specific time,
but if you didn't think
that, that's totally fine,
and your reading is
superior to mine.
I would say any reader out there.
>> Well, I think in a sense that --
it was so internal in that it was
so about them that if some
catastrophic something happened
in the world that they live in,
whether they live in 2005 or,
you know, 1995 or whatever,
that I didn't think it
would have a dramatic --
>> Oh, yeah.
>> It wasn't reliant on what was
happening in the world outside.
>> Oh, yeah.
They're very ingrown.
>> That's what I mean by --
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
>> Being timeless.
>> Yeah. They're deeply
in love, yes.
>> Right.
>> And when you are, you look at the
person, and their face is in front
of you no matter where
you are in the world,
so, yeah, yeah, thank you.
>> It was a great book.
>> Thank you for reading it.
I appreciate it.
>> Well done.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. So this is just a kind
of generic author question,
but what's one book you've
read recently and loved?
>> Oh, darn!
You're doing this one!
I always forget.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can do it.
I can do this.
Okay, "The Marriage of
Cadmus and Harmony."
I think that's right.
Yes, "The Marriage of
Cadmus," by Roberto Calasso.
It's an extraordinary, extraordinary
book that says it's a novel,
but it's not really, it's
about Greek mythology,
but it's not really.
I mean, it's like amazing.
It's a classic, classic,
classic, yeah.
Yeah. I don't know if it's recent.
I don't think so, but
it's really good.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>> You speak so passionately --
you speak so passionately about
your characters and, like,
you spend so much time with them.
When the book is done, someone
else tells you it's done,
do you still think about them?
Do you think about
what they're doing?
What comes next for them, and how do
you deal with that if they're still
in your brain, and you're
trying to write something else?
>> So it's really hard.
So there's an expanse between when
you finish a book and when it comes
out in the world, and for
me that's always a period
of just tremendous
grieving, actually.
So, and then when it
comes out in the world,
it becomes other people's book, and
it's not mine to grieve anymore,
which is really healthy, right?
But in those few months, I actually
get pretty depressed about it.
I mean, especially with
"Arcadia," because it was
so deeply personal, that book.
I was so sad that I was never
going to see Bit again in my life.
And this book, you know,
I know Mathilde is tough,
she'll be fine without me.
She doesn't need me.
But Bit does.
I just want to go back and
protect him, because, you know,
I based him on what I
projected my son to be like.
And he's not at all like him, but
that character is almost his ghost,
is a different person, so,
yeah, it's really hard.
>> Hi. I have a really
random question.
>> Great.
>> I'm from Gainesville,
Florida, actually.
I'm sure we know a lot
of the same people.
And I was reading The New Yorker,
and I came across your story
that was published like a
year ago, I think it was.
But I didn't look at the
-- your name or the title,
I just saw the photo
that was with the story,
and I recognized the
street actually.
And I was wondering if
you could just tell me
where that photo was
taken, because I knew --
I said, oh, this is
Gainesville when I saw the photo,
and then I read the story
and it was clearly about,
like, the duck pond, and --
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> And neighborhoods I used to
live in, so I was just wondering
if you could tell me if you knew.
Did you choose that photo?
>> No, we have no decision
making abilities at all in terms
of the artwork with our
stories in The New Yorker.
In fact, you don't even see
them until it gets published
and you're like, oh, that's perfect.
So I have no idea, no.
But it really is about
the duck pond.
And the funny thing about this
is that I put the story out kind
of cringingly, because I'm
talking not incredibly positively
about the duck pond and the way
that we treat homeless
people in particular.
And my mailman rang my doorbell,
and I always get The New Yorker
about a week later
than everyone else,
I think you might be reading it.
But he did read the story, and
he goes, "I read your story.
I didn't like it."
And I was like, okay, like
every fear I've ever had
like crashing down on my head.
And he goes, "I didn't like
it, because I wasn't in it."
[ Laughter ]
>> That's Gainesville.
>> That's Gainesville, I know.
Yes. Go Gators.
>> I really loved your book.
It was one of the first books to
really consume me in my adulthood,
and there were a few moments that
I truly found myself resetting
and absorbing the book, and
those were the moments of text
in between the brackets, as well
as the characters'
interactions with their dog.
And I was wondering if you
could share a little bit
about how you utilized the
brackets, and the character of God.
>> Sure. The dog, his name is God.
So I thought it was funny.
It wasn't funny, but.
The brackets.
They came out of my obsessive
re-reading of "To the Lighthouse,"
by Virginia Woolf, which is one
of the best books of all times,
and if you haven't
read it, run to get it.
But "To the Lighthouse"
is so extraordinary,
because it's three
parts, and the first
and the third part are this
stream of consciousness in
and out of people's minds.
The first part, in
particular, sort of centered
around the figure of
the mother, right?
Mrs. Ramsey.
So beautiful, so loving.
And the second part is this part
called Time Passes, and in itself,
it's just, basically a short
story, and what happens
with this is it's one of the most
extraordinary literary feats I've
ever read.
The human is leeched
out, and what comes
in in its place is
sort of elemental time.
The time of wind, and
the time of the sea,
and the time of the house
that's slowly disintegrating
without the people in it.
And then when the people come
into it, it's in the brackets.
And it's devastating.
It's like a nail in your heart,
because the best death of all times
in literature, is the
death of Mrs. Ramsey.
And it's really short.
It's in brackets, and it's
something like, and I'm not going
to get it right, because I
can never quote things right.
It's something like "Mr.
Ramsey coming into the hall
in the morning reached out his
arms for Mrs. Ramsey, but she,
having died in the
night, is not there."
And it's like the worst thing ever.
But it's so wonderful.
So what I wanted to do is, I read
it and I read it, and I read it,
and what I loved about
it, is that it's a way
to bring what I was talking about
earlier, the Greek sort of sense
of larger time and smaller time at
the same time into the same book.
And so I have this granular human
time with Lotto and Mathilde,
and then this larger, almost
elemental time in the voices
of whatever you read it to be.
I am, it's very specific to me what
the voice is, but coming in almost
like a hawk, and then swooping up
the rabbit and going away, right?
So that's the way I
saw this voice as.
Also, it serves to stitch
the two books into one.
Yeah.
>> Great.
>> Thank you for your question.
Hi.
>> May I ask a question
about "Arcadia?"
>> Yeah.
>> First of all, it's
such a lovely book.
It's -- the language in it,
your writing is so beautiful.
I had to hand it over to
friends to read whole passages.
One of things I wanted to know was
how you captured the communal life
so vividly, and your
descriptions of it were so --
what I imagined are true to life,
and I was wondering what
your process was in capturing
that whole lifestyle and
everything like that.
>> Sure. So I have never been
in a community like that.
I've lived in one for three
days, or a week or something.
It was a very short amount of time.
But when I write, I try to write
out of longing, and at the time
that I was writing that book,
I was really isolated
in Gainesville, Florida.
I was pregnant and I
had my son in a place
where I didn't really know
anybody but my mother-in-law
and my husband, and
I work alone, right?
I am a hermit, basically,
and I go outside to exercise,
but that involves no people.
So I was super, super disassociated
from the rest of the world,
and I longed to have
a community of people
who could take care of me, right?
And could take care of my
kid when I needed a break.
And so out of that longing, I
guess, and out of my research --
I did a great deal of research for
that book, particularly in terms
of the farm, which is
this commune in Tennessee
that was amazingly
successful for a long time.
And Oneida, which was this
other utopian-esque community
in Upstate New York, super nuts.
If you want to read about
a really crazy commune,
you, I mean, it's awesome.
They did everything right and wrong.
The right things they did were women
were equal to men in the, you know,
mid to late 19th century.
The wrong things they did
were eugenics, and, you know.
And spiritual elders, men,
having sex with 12-year-olds.
So all of that.
That's really wrong.
So it collapsed under
its own weight.
I'm sorry.
I went off course.
But it's really fascinating.
So I did a ton of research, and
I imagined through longing my way
into a community, which, in a way,
is what I did with "Monsters," too,
because I wanted to be home,
I wanted to be in Cooperstown,
and all I wanted to do was
spend hours a day there.
So, yeah, imagination, basically.
Yeah, thank you.
>> One more question.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Hi. I feel so privileged.
So what I really loved
about "The Fates
and the Furies" was how you read
it, and then you read it again,
and there's just this
total shift in perspective.
And obviously every character
is a facet of oneself.
But how did you manage to make
such distinguished characters
with such different personalities,
and how are you able
to tap into that?
>> Thank you.
I wish I knew, if it were true, too.
But I think it might have something
to do with the way I write,
because through writing layer
after layer after layer,
what I feel like I'm doing is
actually creating this world that's
almost three-dimensional.
Almost like a 3D printer, right?
So what happens then is that because
you have this three-dimensional
world, you can choose
your path through it.
And the path usually
doesn't involve a lot
of the side stories
that I threw out, right?
But those side stories are really
important for the side characters
in a lot of ways, and they're
really important to sort
of give information to
the main characters, too.
And eventually, if you do that
enough, if you write enough layers,
you believe these people
are actually human beings.
I mean, I remember once, I was
in the middle of both "Arcadia"
and "Fates and Furies," because I
was writing them at the same time,
and I was at the dinner table with
my family, and I started laughing.
My husband was like, what?
And I was like, something
that Lotto said today.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
He doesn't exist, this is crazy.
But, like I said, it's
hard to be married to me.
But I guess that's,
you know, I don't know,
but I hope that that's why.
>> Thank you so much for coming.
>> Thank you.
>> It's such a pleasure
to talk to you.
>> Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.